people had this
picture-perfect thing that it was going
to be sunshine and rainbows and he was
going to have a whole lot of one-on-ones
it's odell beckham
he's going to have double coverage we
have to find ways to format things to
get him the ball
and force feed him early on to where he
can make an impact before we can you
know have the perfect look to give him a
shot play
and i think that's something that we
learned the hard way
but you know i think as the weeks have
gone on we're continuing to improve on
how to get the ball to
that is baker mayfield cleveland browns
quarterback talking about the latest
strategy for getting the football into
the hands of otto beckham jr and oh
chris i continue to take the position
that
you shouldn't worry about who's getting
the ball the open man gets the ball i
don't like the idea of force feeding
otto beckham jr because you're telling
the world that's what you're going to do
so now early in games what are defenses
going to do they're going to key on otto
beckham jr even more yeah i get that i
mean and you're right to a degree i mean
you don't want to force feed somebody to
where it takes you out of the rhythm of
your offense but you know let's hey i
mean
we knew when like rob gronkowski was
playing for the new england patriots
they were going to try to throw the ball
to rob gronkowski and teams were going
oh we're going to double rob gronkowski
today and then we'd look up and we go
damn rob gronkowski had seven catches
for 120 yards and they said they were
going to double team them today what the
hell happened you know and to what else
you're saying too you know sometimes
when you feature a guy like that and i
know you've heard me say this before it
starts to make a team go a defensive
team that's playing them go oh we got to
put more eggs into the let's stop odell
beckham jr basket and that can lead to
more balls for everybody else my big
thing with them is i think they need to
move them around more you know you know
as far as bunches and stacks make it
hard for teams to double team him and
things like that to where he comes
through the trash of two or three wide
receivers and it's kind of like oh we
don't know where he's gonna end up
instead of just making him a stationary
oh he's lined out to the outside on the
left you know that's he's they're making
it a little too easy on defense is the
key on the key on him that way and
that's where i would like to see he's
double covered here but baker mayfield
just said to hell with it it's odell and
i'm gonna just throw a back shoulder
ball that he can get his hands on and go
from it there uh you know even there i
believe he might have been bracketed by
a safety on the other side but
to my point and what i'm saying you're
seeing he's lined up on the outside
every time pittsburgh didn't do that
with antonio brown they would move him
motion him motion him next to other
receivers to make it hard for teams to
double him because it messes up their
communication their calls everything
like that
did the giants do that with him they not
as much as they should have but they did
yes they definitely did they found ways
to move him around uh when they wanted
to get him the ball
and you know the other thing is there i
will always say this about eli manning
eli manning when he saw odell beckham jr
one on one it the ball was going there
it didn't matter so he he would go the
hell with the damn play it's odell one
on one i like the matchup i'm gonna do
that and he learned that very quickly
that could be a very successful formula
now towards the end it hurt a little bit
because
you know eli didn't always want to stand
in the pocket maybe take the shot deep
down the field or maybe not even have
the arm to launch it deep down the field
so that's where it kind of fell off at
the end but yes the giants and his
heyday there uh they were moving them
around definitely more than he's moving
around right now
well and here's the other side of it as
well um
he may not be comfortable in these other
spots right i mean receivers aren't
always comfortable in the x the y and
the z sometimes you know i go to the
left side i want the left side i don't
want the right side i don't want to be
in the slot this is this is the spot
that i'm the most comfortable in getting
the play started now we see him on the
outside on either side but it may just
be he's not as comfortable operating out
of the slot chris yeah maybe but i think
he's he'll be comfortable anywhere once
he goes oh the play doh designs for me
and it's kind of creative and it's going
to give me some space or create a
one-on-one you know that's where i just
don't see like where's odell beckham jr
over the middle why don't we ever see
deep crosses to odell beckham jr and
things like that and that comes a lot of
times with like okay here's two
receivers and here's odell beckham jr
getting in the bunch and these two
receivers go vertical and do something
and he kind of plays off behind him and
the defense doesn't know like oh is he
going to go right or is he going to go
left i don't know what he's going to do
and then he breaks it off for a deep
cross or you know something of that
nature is really what i'm just trying to
say and uh i know freddie kitchens has
got his hands full baker mayfield's
still learning on the fly but i do think
ultimately that's the thing that i would
like to change about them and odell
right now
and that's really the bottom line it's
not odell beckham jr all of a sudden not
being one of the best receivers in the
nfl right the browns haven't figured out
how to properly use him they haven't
designed the plays they haven't used the
creativity that is available to them i
don't know what they expected would
happen i think they just thought it
would be automatic and it would be
simple it would be easy and sometimes
when you have a great receiver like that
it makes it harder for the coach it
makes it harder for the quarterback
because he's so different than what
you're used to everybody else is just
interchangeable parts right there's otto
beckham jr what are we gonna do yeah
when is he truly open a lot of times
when he's double covered like you showed
earlier he still is open and he's gonna
make the catch you just have to trust
him and throw it to him yeah you do and
you know it's something that goes to the
off season too and maybe that's where
odell deserves a little blame too where
you have them there and you tinker with
ideas and otas and things like that to
find ways to get them the ball
that's the closest you've ever come to
criticizing him i'm proud of you you've
shown growth you've got maturity i am
getting there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports